disons les choses clairement ces
auditions ont suscité chez moi chez les
membres de la commission de l'étonnement
et parfois de la consternation parce que
le récit qui s'est reconstitué devant
nous c'est bien le récit d'une lente
dérive d'une forme de divagation
politique une divagation qui nous a
éloigné et de la transition écologique
et de notre souveraineté énergétique
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP pour
ce nouveau numéro des grands débats
aujourd'hui retour sur un travail
parlementaire majeur celui d'une
commission d'enquête les députés
cherchent à comprendre comment la France
a perdu peu à peu de son indépendance
énergétique ils vont questionner les
choix de politique énergétique avec une
question centrale comment la France qui
disposait d'énergie en abondance c'était
le retrouver à devoir importer son
électricité à l'hiver 2022 emmené par
les députés Raphaël schelenberger et
Antoine Armand les députés commencent
leurs auditions en novembre 2022 avec
l'ingénieur Jean-Marc Jancovici fervent
défenseur de la transition énergétique
mais aussi du nucléaire
Monsieur Jean coup ici je vous prie donc
de lever la main droite et de dire je le
J je le jure je le jure merci je vous
laisse donc la parole pour un propos
introductif très bien en fait mon propos
introductif va être relativement bref
parce que j'imagine que c'est surtout
vous qui avez des questions
je vais juste faire deux commentaires un
sur mes titres et ce au nom duquel je
m'exprime ou pas
et le deuxième commentaire que je vais
faire c'est sur l'intitulé même de la
commission d'enquête
en ce qui concerne mes titres donc je
précise que je ne m'exprime au nom
d'aucune des instances pour lesquelles
mon figure ici donc je ne suis pas du
tout habilité à m'exprimer au nom du
Haut Conseil pour le climat qui a une
présidente qui fait ça très bien je suis
pas plus habilité à m'exprimer au nom
des mines ni au nom de carbone cap donc
ce que je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui
n'engage pas car 24 et ni au nom du gif
project voilà ça non ça n'engagera que
moi la deuxième chose que je souhaite
préciser en ce qui concerne le titre
même de votre commission la France n'a
jamais été indépendante énergétiquement
depuis qu'elle a quitté l'air des
énergies renouvelables c'est-à-dire que
nous étions indépendant énergétiquement
à l'époque où nous utilisons
exclusivement les pierres et le bois du
sol français pour construire des moulins
à vent les pierres du sol français
pourri de bois pour construire des
moulins à eau et le bois français et
l'herbe française pour faire avancer des
animaux de traits depuis que nous sommes
rentrés dans l'ère des combustibles
fossiles et de l'énergie nucléaire et
des nouvelles énergies renouvelables etc
en fait nous ne sommes pas indépendants
parce que nous dépend d'une espèce
d'imbrication des énergies je sais pas
si l'historiens des énergies qui est
venue ici c'est Jean-Baptiste Fressoz
non c'est pas lui mais sinon en fait il
y a une implication des énergies qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
dégager une énergie de façon
individualisée d'un système elles sont
toutes imbriquées et par exemple on ne
fait pas de réacteurs nucléaire sans
métallurgie donc sans charbon on ne fait
pas de panneaux photovoltaïques sans
électricité au charbon donc son charbon
on ne fait pas on ne fait pas venir
depuis la Chine sans pétrole parce que
il faut que ça vienne donc en fait il y
a une imprimation des énergies
aujourd'hui et sauf à ce qu'un pays
maîtrise sur son sol la totalité à la
fois des sources énergétiques impliquées
donc la totalité des énergies
actuellement utilisées dans le monde et
la totalité des mines métalliques qui
sont nécessaires pour fournir les
dispositifs d'extraction de l'énergie de
l'environnement et de transformation en
des vecteurs énergétiques qui permettent
d'alimenter nos machines et bien on ne
peut pas parler d'indépendance
énergétique ou de souveraineté
énergétique donc en fait aucun pays ne
la possède totalement
l'Arabie saoudite a plus de pétrole que
nous mais elle a pas de mine de fer donc
si elle était à frontière fermée sans
aucune communication avec l'extérieur
elle ne pourrait pas exploiter son
pétrole voilà donc c'était juste un
petit une petite remarque préliminaire
pour dire que les mots ayant un sens
enfin en tout cas j'imagine qu'ils en
ont un dans la Commission dans le titre
de la commission d'enquête
je voulais juste faire remarquer que
l'indépendance ça n'existe pas stricte
au sang et que la bonne question pour
moi me semble être pour l'ensemble du
système énergétique de savoir de qui on
dépend
dans quelle proportion avec quelle
aptitude à se retourner si jamais on a
un problème avec les gens dont on dépend
voilà c'est ça les bonnes questions et
donc c'est des questions qui sont
nécessairement quantifiées et calendez
avoir un débat c'est pas du tout
agressif ce que je veux dire mais avoir
à débat philosophiques sur
l'indépendance en fait c'est très
intéressant le soir passé 23 heures mais
sinon dans l'absolu ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'intérêts pratiques
expert au fonctionnaires industriels
sont entendus par les députés l'audition
de Patrick pouillané PDG de Total
énergie est un moment fort de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire son
groupe fait partie des majors du pétrole
mais la crise sanitaire de 2020 est la
nouvelle donne sur le marché de l'or
noir ont conduit son groupe amusé
davantage sur les énergies renouvelables
son groupe qui garde aussi un lien très
particulier avec l'État
nous mettons 4 milliards d'euros nous
invissions 4 milliards de dollars ou
d'euros c'est pareil en l'occurrence sur
16 dans les énergies renouvelables et
des carbonées électricité oui c'est ce
qui est on n'arrête pas de me dire que
c'est pas assez parce qu'on regarde le
verre de la vérité c'est qu'on doit être
la cinquième le plus gros cinquième plus
gros industrie d'investisseurs au monde
pour une seule entreprise dans ces
secteurs alors bien sûr on peut faire le
rapport au profit mais oui non mais les
capacités d'investissement d'une
entreprise sont pas décidé en fonction
des profils de l'année mais on regarde
le sujet on a décidé qu'on est annoncé
qu'on augmenterait nos investissements
et on va les augmenter ils passeront
sans doute les prochaines à plus de 5
milliards alors après on peut me poser
la question qu'il a pas beaucoup
d'intérêt pour être honnête pour faire
un ratio que vous faites entre
aujourd'hui et effectivement pour
pouvoir produire il faut d'abord
investir ça c'est la définition on a dit
qu'on va on a dit qu'en 2011 on visait
d'avoir 20% de notre mix en 2030 dans
les énergies électriques et
renouvelables donc c'est ça l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est petit bien évidemment
puisqu'on a commencé à trois ou quatre
ans donc je sais pas le de j'ai pas le
don de lèche pas la baguette magique
effectivement et que dans l'énergie il
faut se dire pendant des années avant de
pouvoir produire donc voilà et et
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le la balance
qu'on doit faire et c'est un débat
permanent au niveau de notre avec le
conseil d'administration c'est en même
temps on nous demande aussi de fournir
le pétrole et gaz dont vous avez besoin
le gaz naturel donc on doit trouver le
bon équilibre entre fourni à l'énergie
qui nous fait vivre aujourd'hui et
construire et investir dans l'énergie de
demain je pense que toute manière donc
c'est le vert de midi donc le verre à
demi plein
nous on considère en tout cas que les
chiffres sont là qu'on est un des
acteurs les plus les plus les plus qui
investissent sont le plus dans ces
énergies là en ce moment au niveau
mondial notre mission c'était quelque
part de fournir plus d'énergie au monde
parce qu'effectivement notre champ il
est mondial il n'est pas français ou
européen et en même temps moins
d'émissions c'est ça toute la stratégie
de l'entreprise c'est d'aller piloter
les deux en même temps et pour faire
cela ce qui est durable effectivement
pour pouvoir investir dans les énergies
renouvelables c'est parce que je fais
des profits sur le reste si j'ai pas
trouvé encore la la machine à investir
sans faire des profits ça je ne sais pas
faire il y a l'Europe il y a le reste du
monde la consommation encore une fois la
population mondiale croit
et dans tout ce débat
la question est de savoir c'est le pas
d'ailleurs l'accord de Paris est un
accord sur le pari sur le climat et le
développement c'est le titre qu'il porte
on a bien vu à Charmed cher que le débat
sur le développement était aussi présent
et donc la question pour les pays
émergents qui ont une population qui a
légitimement légitime demande d'accès
elle aussi à l'énergie à un bien-être
que nous on a dans nos pays occidentaux
un besoin de plus d'énergie et tout le
débat tout l'enjeu compliqué c'est
comment on fait pour expliquer je vais
essayer du temps en Afrique du Sud
récemment à l'Afrique du Sud d'éviter de
continuer à créer des centrales au
charbon
or leur seule ressource naturelle pour
l'instant majeur c'est le charbon qui
emploie d'ailleurs des centaines de
milliers de personnes donc je pense
qu'il y a c'est ça le débat qu'on doit
avoir si on est responsable nous
européen c'est pas de s'occuper
seulement de nos émissions
c'est combien sommes-nous prêts à
apporter à ces pays-là pour être capable
eux aussi de faire la transition mais
leur demander de rester dans le
dénuement économique et social ça ça me
paraît pas la bonne réponse donc
effectivement l'essentiel des
productions que nous faisons aujourd'hui
d'ores et déjà elles ont une vocation
pas seulement au marché européen en
français et la majorité de nos
productions d'ores et déjà va vers ces
économies là la croissance aujourd'hui
de la demande elle vient de ces pays là
la commission d'enquête consacre une
large part de ses travaux au nucléaire
l'énergie historique elle entend les
principaux acteurs de la filière
notamment trois anciens présidents d'EDF
Pierre gadoneix Henri Proglio et
Jean-Daniel Lévy les trois hommes vont
se livrer à un réquisitoire implacable
contre le marché européen de
l'électricité
nous étions convaincus que s'il y avait
une ouverture du marché c'était EDF
qu'elle est gagnant puisqu'on avait les
meilleurs tarifs de d'Europe donc ça
nous est gênait pas par contre toute
idée qui était de submant chez les
concurrents qui venaient avec la reine
je peux vous dire que quand j'en ai
entendu parler là j'ai hurlé j'ai jamais
dit j'ai toujours dit non la reine est
une monstruosité monstruosité je sais
pas si vous le mesurez alors pourquoi on
a mis la reine c'est pas pas de mon
temps
quand l'idée a été évoqué je hurlais
c'est absurde qu'est-ce qui justifie que
DF subventionne ses concurrents
alors je fais l'avocat de adverse la
justification c'est de dire que DF a de
fait un monopole en ayant le coup du
nucléaire et que personne ne peut en
bénéficier et donc personne ne pourra
jamais investir dans ce domaine donc la
seule manière pour que les autres
puissent investir c'est qu'ils aient une
partie de la rampe nucléaire voilà la
justification
regardez aucun de ceux qui ont bénéficié
de la rente d'investi ni dans le
nucléaire ni dans même dans la
production
ou très peu sauf total qui a les moyens
qui a pas besoin de ça pour le faire le
problème c'est que Bruxelles
conscient de ça à introduit des pilules
empoisonnées pour empêcher EDF de
s'imposer sur le marché
la reine est une pilule empoisonnée
c'est une manière de d'empêcher EDF de
bénéficier de sa honte c'est clair
donc je pense que la reine est quelque
chose
qu'on n'aurait jamais dû accepter alors
c'est c'est une collusion bruxelloise et
allemande parce que il faut savoir que
l'Allemagne a toujours été très
[Musique]
honnêtement le poids politique allemand
était très
conscient que la France avait un
avantage
particulier avec les prix d'électricité
bas et y compris l'industriellement
parce que à cette époque là j'ai pas dit
de mon temps les tarifs pratiqués par
EDF dans le pour le secteur domestique
et industriel était nettement inférieur
à ce qui se passait en Allemagne de
l'ordre de 30% nettement inférieur et
donc Bruxelles et les Allemands
considéraient que c'était une distorsion
de concurrence
pourquoi prendre la France un otage de
ce genre de réglementation absurde
comment est-ce qu'on explique cette
réglementation je voudrais que qu'on est
simplement la question de fond c'est
pour qui à quoi
sert ces réglementations
quel est le but
alors à chaque fois on me dit oui mais
le but comprenez on fait le bonheur du
peuple
libre concurrence mais il y a qu'un seul
producteur camarade
la libre concurrence
il était clair que ça
se traduire par un désastre
on y assiste aujourd'hui
la deuxième moi géniale c'est la loi
d'Ohm que vous avez rappelé qui sont
consiste à imposer à EDF la vente a pris
casser puisque inférieur au coût de
revient de 25% de sa production
électronucléaire assez propre
concurrents pour qu'ils puissent vendre
son énergie valeur aux clients
ça a très bien fonctionné ils sont
devenus riches
c'est d'une pertinence absolue
je l'ai dénoncé pendant des années avec
l'efficacité que vous voyez
et puis pour couronner le tout il
fallait quand même définir un prix de
marché puisqu'il n'y avait pas de marché
défini un prix de marché prix de marché
qui a été indexé sur quoi sur le gaz
j'aime bien pourquoi sur le gaz
puisqu'on n'utilise pas parce que les
Allemands utilisent le gaz
et que toutes ces démarches c'est une
démarche allemande tout argumentation
européenne réglementation allemande je
voudrais dans un premier temps avant de
répondre à vos questions
m'attarder sur deux des causes qui me
semblent primordial dans l'analyse du
sujet de votre enquête quand j'arrive
chez EDF c'est fin 2014 qu'elle n'est
pas ma surprise de prendre conscience
des implications de la loi norme la loi
du 7 décembre 2010 qui institut un
mécanisme la reine l'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique un
mécanisme pernicieux qui va croissant
sur l'endettement de déesse au rythme
d'environ 3 à 4 milliards d'euros chaque
année d'accroissement de l'endettement
d'EDF je l'ai dit répéter pendant 8 ans
la reine est un poison pour EDF et je
voudrais expliciter avec vous les trois
raisons qui font de la reine un poison
tout d'abord le prix le prix est de 42
euros pour un mégawh il est inchangé
depuis l'instauration de la reine le 1er
janvier 2011 et j'observe que ce prix
s'appliquera encore sur l'exercice 2023
ce prix est manifestement sous-évalué
par rapport au prix de revient de notre
production nucléaire je me réfère par
exemple au calcul détaillé qui ont été
produits en 2019 par la creux la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
pourtant elle est peu suspecte de
soutien à l'égard de DF cette
sous-évaluation engendre un
affaiblissement systématique de déesse
et je vais y revenir mais je voudrais
d'abord vous dire qu'au moment même de
mon arrivée en 2014 devant cette
sous-évaluation manifeste le
gouvernement français et la Commission
européenne avait engagé des discussions
approfondi pour augmenter la valeur de
l'arène faire passer la valeur d'un
mégawattheure d'arène de 42 à 52 euros
par palier de 2 euros chaque année
et là cette négociation a pris fin assez
vite lorsque le prix du mégawattheure
sur le marché de gros européen est tombé
sous les 42 euros c'était dans les
derniers mois de 2015 et nous en sommes
depuis rester à 42 euros et lorsque le
prix de gros tombe sous les 42 euros
comme fin 2015 et en 2016 nous voyons
naturellement les opérateurs
concurrentes de DF dédaigner tout achat
à la reine pour acheter sur le marché à
un prix inférieur et en cela EDF est en
somme une deuxième fois victime de la
reine puisque ce mécanisme revient à
donner une option gratuite aux
concurrent d'EDF dont bien évidemment
ses concurrents font usage qu'on
opportunité se présente cette
caractéristique tout à fait étonnante et
décrite par le mot asymétrie
au cœur des critiques le marché européen
de l'énergie a aussi ses défenseurs
l'ancien directeur de cabinet d'Edouard
Philippe Benoît ribado Dumas ou encore
Elisabeth borne qui a été directrice de
cabinet de Ségolène Royal mais aussi
ministre de la transition écologique
en fait il y a deux façons de regarder
la reine il y a la façon
vue d'EDF de considérer que c'est une
contrainte et que c'est empêche de
maximiser le chiffre d'affaires et les
revenus c'est une façon de regarder la
reine il y a une autre façon de regarder
la reine
qui est que c'est une tresse c'est une
très puissante protection
des consommateurs français face à
fortiori à des fluctuations du prix de
l'électricité qui ont été très
importantes ces derniers mois et moi je
nous invite vraiment à regarder ces deux
volets de la reine
un certain nombre de nos voisins
considèrent que c'est une forme de
soutien
comment dire
auquel il souhaiterait pouvoir accéder
pour leur industrie c'est un outil
majeur de soutien à la compétitivité de
nos industries c'est un outil majeur
pour éviter d'exposer les consommateurs
français à des fluctuations du prix de
l'électricité une fois qu'on a dit ça
il y a clairement des choses qui ne qui
ne sont pas satisfaisantes dans le
mécanisme actuel par exemple quand
j'étais ministre de l'énergie à un
moment donné les prix de marché étaient
passés sous des prix de la reine pendant
le covid et on a vu les
consommateurs enfin les oui les clients
rentre de la reine
AEDF qui du coup ne n'avait pas anticipé
la vente de ces volumes d'électricité et
a été pris de cours et ça a été
certainement préjudiciable pour EDF donc
je suis pas en train de dire que c'est
un mécanisme parfait il y a certainement
des enjeux de symétrie dans le mécanisme
mais franchement
on a montré le gouvernement a montré les
gouvernements successifs ont montré
qu'on était aux côtés d'EDF quand ils
ont pu avoir des difficultés financières
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait d'une
part en tête la situation financière de
DF l'importance de cette entreprise
l'importance cruciale de cette
entreprise pour notre pays la nécessité
de s'assurer que EDF a bien tous les
moyens de son développement
et c'est ce qu'on a montré au cours des
dernières années et en même temps que ça
ne nous conduise pas à renoncer à ce
qu'est un outil
sans doute améliorer à réformer à
adapter un outil majeur sur la
compétitivité de notre économie et de
nos industries et de protection des
ménages français je sais pas ce que les
présidents vous ont dit moi j'ai été
frappé dans les écoutant sur le côté je
vous disais un petit peu de mentalité
d'acier de DF moi j'ai un immense
respect pour cette entreprise je
considère qu'elle n'a pas toujours été
aidée par les gouvernements par la
régulation européenne c'est tout à fait
exact c'est tout à fait exact mais le
problème il est d'abord et avant tout un
problème industriel qu'il faut régler
qu'il faut régler et le le marché la
reine l'Europe le gouvernement peuvent
pas être uniquement des bouquets
mystères pour expliquer tous les
problèmes de DF ils en expliquent
certains je suis le premier à vous le
concéder il explique pas tous les
problèmes de DF le marché n'est pas
responsable de l'industrialité des
réacteurs
l'interconnexion européenne le marché
européen c'est plus de ça a été
longtemps une chance pour EDF qui
exporte quand même qui a créé un peu de
surcapacité à la fin des années 90 et
qui était bien content d'ex
et un arène qu'il faut évidemment
rénover un arène avec la fin des
aberrations du droit d'option
des fournisseurs alternatifs et avec une
indexation plus raisonnable un arène en
soi c'est plutôt un instrument assez
sain de protection du consommateur et
qui serait une régulation pas absurde
pour le nouvel pour le futur EDF donc il
faut pas jeter avec le bébé avec l'eau
du bain sur ces sujets là et c'est vrai
aussi très vrai qu'il est plus difficile
de motiver
de recruter de motiver des ingénieurs
quand on se fait critiquer toute la
journée mais pardon de le dire
totalement si ce fut critiquer toute la
journée les entreprises de plastique
elles se font critiquer toute la journée
et pourtant elles ont quand même les
meilleurs conduites de projets du monde
donc il y a un moment donné voilà le
problème de DF c'est aussi un problème
industriel qu'il faut qu'il règle il y a
un nouveau patron d'EDF qui est tout à
fait remarquable il faut faire très
attention à ce que dans la
transformation de DF dont sa
nationalisation dans dans ce qui se
profile on en fasse pas
un arsenal soumis à quatre tutelles de
l'État 3 autorités administratives
indépendantes et que on en oublie que
d'abord et avant tout on veut retrouver
l'excellence industrielle qui a souvent
été qui a longtemps été et qui est
toujours dans beaucoup de domaines la
caractéristique de d'EDF
la commission d'enquête parlementaire
entendent de nombreuses personnalités
toujours en fonction ou en retrait de la
vie publique parmi elles Lionel Jospin
l'ancien Premier ministre socialiste de
1997 à 2002 revient sur les choix qui
ont été les siens lorsqu'il était au
responsabilité
avec le recul du temps je pense pouvoir
dire en réponse aux interrogations les
victimes qui sont les vôtres que la
politique conduite entre
1997 et 2002 n'a pas entraîné une perte
de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique pour la France
pendant les cinq années de mon
gouvernement le nucléaire sera une
composante essentielle de la politique
énergétique du pays nos actions dans le
champ du nucléaire civil viseront donc à
renforcer la filière industrielle et à
lui redonner sa crédibilité dans
l'opinion je vais énumérer brièvement
maintenant ces actions
certes nous avons fermé super Phénix
à ceux qui ont dit que ce choix était
strictement politique je répondrai ceci
en annonçant cette intention dans
l'accord signé avec les vers nous avons
informé dument l'opinion avant les
législatives et les électeurs ont fait
leur choix car la politique c'est aussi
instaurer une relation de confiance avec
les citoyens par la transparence en
outre en démocratie
dirait-on que les choix énergétiques qui
engagent un pays sur des dizaines
d'années sont purement techniques et non
pas politique ce serait singulier
pour autant les raisons de la fermeture
de super Phénix ont été avant tout
industriels la technologie du
surgénérateur était séduisante
théoriquement le plutonium obtenu lors
de l'utilisation de l'uranium dans les
centrales classiques laissent s'être
espérer un usage comme combustible pour
produire de l'électricité dans la
filière du surgénérateur en outre la
transmutation espérée des matières
nucléaires semblait ouvrir une voie à
l'élimination des déchets
mais la centrale dite sur générateur
lancé à Chris Malville en 1977
est terminée en 1987 était un échec
industriel elle n'avait jamais
fonctionné de façon stable elle avait
subi ainsi dans sur un sidant et connu
de longs arrêts de fonctionnement les
technologies employées étaient risquées
puisque le sodium explose au contact de
l'eau et elle n'était pas maîtrisée
après 20 ans d'efforts
le projet qui devenait lourd
financièrement pour EDF ne promettait
pas le succès par contre les recherches
sur la transmutation des déchets
nucléaires ont été poursuivis par la
relance du réacteur Phoenix
en outre la fermeture de super Phénix ne
fragilisait pas la sécurité énergétique
du pays
notons en effet que le projet Astrid de
réacteurs à neutrons rapides repris par
le CEA en 2010 a été à son tour arrêté
25 ans après notre décision cette
technologie n'a prospérer dans aucun
pays
occidental notamment pas aux États-Unis
au Japon qu'il avait exploré même si
elle semble avoir 6 semble-t-il elle a
débouché en Russie et peut-être en Chine
dans des conditions que nous ne
connaissons guère ainsi solder l'échec
industriel était une décision
rationnelle et raisonnable qui ne
portait atteinte ni à la dépendance ni à
la souveraineté énergétique du pays
pour comprendre les choix successifs qui
ont été ceux de la France en matière de
politique énergétique la commission
d'enquête recueille le témoignage
d'anciens ministres en charge de la
transition écologique
quand moi j'étais ministre je pense que
ça a été pareil après moi ça y est
jamais de décision qui sont prises en
ayant mis autour de la même table des
représentants d'ONG des représentants de
syndicats ou autre donc c'était quelque
chose avant de particulier qui ne sait
pas renouvelé sous la même forme et qui
de toute façon proposer un certain
nombre de choses et ensuite le
gouvernement elle Parlement prenait leur
décision mais en tout cas quand moi je
démise j'ai jamais mis sur le même plan
les responsables politiques les
responsables techniques et économiques
de l'énergie
les syndicats et les
ONG donc ça c'est clair et net alors ça
ne veut pas dire que les uns les autres
ne sont pas légitimes à exprimer des
points de vue mais moi je considère que
ce ne doit évidemment pas sous-traiter
la décision par ailleurs je le dis ça a
été publié à ce moment là donc
c'est quelque chose facilement
vérifiable moi je me suis opposé à
plusieurs reprises à certaines ONG comme
campagne par exemple qui a fait un
lobbying intense avec des campagnes
médiatiques avec des coups d'éclat dont
ils ont le secret contre le nucléaire
mais qui n'a jamais rien dit contre les
centrales thermiques et qui d'ailleurs
n'a jamais salué le fait que nous ayons
annoncé la fermeture des centrales à
charbon et je crois que ça a dit
beaucoup de choses sur le fait que sous
couvert de vouloir agir pour le climat
en fait il y a d'autres buts qui sont
poursuivis qui sont un peu des symboles
qui sont un peu les totems voire
peut-être de l'idéologie je ne sais pas
par rapport au nucléaire quand moi j'ai
dit
dans le monde en septembre 2018
j'aimerais qu'on sorte de la guerre de
religion sur le nucléaire bon elle
existe toujours cette guerre de religion
malheureusement je pense que c'est
dommage je je note en revanche avec
intérêt que le climat politique dans
l'opinion a changé depuis
deux trois ans et que aujourd'hui en
France on oppose plus systématiquement
nucléaire énergie nucléaire et écologie
quand moi j'étais ministre des
journalistes me reprenaient dans des
interviews pour me dire vous ne pouvez
pas faire de l'écologie si en même temps
vous faites du nucléaire bon je
considère que pour le climat je l'ai dit
je l'ai écrit d'ailleurs y compris après
lorsque j'avais quitté le ministère j'ai
d'ailleurs évolué sur le sujet et je
l'assume totalement que le nucléaire est
une contribution importante pour relever
le défi climatique et que pour avoir une
énergie décarbonée le choix qui a été
fait de fait entre lequel j'ai participé
entre 2017 et 2022 c'est un choix qui
consiste à avoir à la fois un
développement des renouvelables et
également un maintien et un
renouvellement du nucléaire
autre audition marquante celle d'Arnaud
Montebourg l'ancien ministre socialiste
du redressement productif est aussi un
fervent défenseur de la souveraineté
industrielle de la France dans les
secteurs stratégiques dont l'énergie
fait partie
j'étais arrivé troisième à la primaire
après avoir mis en ballotage madame
Aubry et Monsieur Hollande
et à l'époque après la distribution des
rôles c'est-à-dire Monsieur Hollande
avait gagné la primaire madame Aubry qui
dirigeait le Parti socialiste et j'étais
dans la majorité de Madame AUBRY donc
j'étais au courant de l'accord qui avait
été passé avec Madame Duflot qui
dirigeait à l'époque
le parti écologique
un accord a été passé entre ces deux
dirigeants de haute qualité
l'une avait été ministre l'autre allait
le devenir et ont pris la décision de
passer un accord de réduire
le nucléaire de 24 réacteurs qui
devaient être fermés d'ici 2025 nous
étions en 2011
et
avec horizon
2025 une limitation à 50% de la
production électrique d'origine
nucléaire qui se traduisait par une
fermeture de 24 réacteurs donc c'est un
accord qui avait été forme négocié
auquel je n'ai pas participé négociation
et je vous avais très vite comprendre
pourquoi mais c'est un accord contre des
circonscriptions ce qu'il y avait 60
circonscriptions qui avaient été
offertes au parti écologiste qui
d'ailleurs a provoqué beaucoup de
réactions y compris en Saône-et-Loire
puisque une dans mon département avait
été affectée à
au parti écologique et j'ai indiqué que
il était hors de question qu'on
soutiennent quelqu'un qui allait taper
sur l'énergie nucléaire et le fermer
dans le département où on produisait les
chaudières nucléaires donc j'ai dit bah
c'est très bien nous présenterons une
candidate qui était une de mes
vice-président du conseil général qui
d'ailleurs a été élu contre le candidat
parce que nous ne voulions pas accepter
cet accord
alors je vous le dis tout de suite tout
le monde s'est posé la question je crois
que vous avez posé la question à
plusieurs dirigeants politiques comment
avait été noué cet accord
l'accord était présenté par Martine
Aubry à l'époque comme un changement de
société et par ces signes Duflot comme
une rupture historique bon pour moi
c'est un accord de cuantables c'est à
dire qu'on s'est mis d'accord sur un
marqueur politique avec de ma manière à
marquer les esprits et on s'est retrouvé
avec un programme qui expliquait qu'il
fallait fermer 24 réacteurs
et après
et ben vogue la galère alors il y a
quand même eu un vote au bureau national
du Parti socialiste il y a eu 33 voix
pour 5 contre j'ai fait partie des 5
il y a eu quelques prises de parole
expliquant que il n'était pas acceptable
que on puisse d'un trade plume brisé une
industrie de cette nature je n'étais pas
le seul mais nous n'étions pas très
nombreux et les réactions qui sont se
sont enchaînées au sein de mon parti de
l'époque ont été surtout liés aux
circonscriptions et bien trop peu au
problème des réacteurs je crois que
monsieur cazen était intervenu à cette
épreuve mais il n'était pas je crois
membre du bureau national mais c'est
exprimé à l'époque et nous étions tout à
fait d'accord donc
c'est c'est de cette date-là qui a
commencé le problème du
l'affaiblissement de la filière
nucléaire même si vous êtes remonté
jusqu'à l'époque du gouvernement Jospin
avec la fermeture du Christ Malville et
du premier acteur
à sodium neutrons rapides enfin là c'est
24 réacteurs en état de marge je vais
vous dire les conséquences que ça a eu
dans le processus décisionnel alors
françois Hollande candidat de notre
parti a déclaré immédiatement le pas
vouloir fermer 24 réacteurs tout en
conservant la fermeture du plus ancien
d'entre eux Fessenheim
et il a maintenu l'objectif des 50%
réduits à horizon 2025 et il est entré à
l'Élysée sur cette base là en quelque
sorte
nettoyer
des excès de l'accord nous étions
confrontés à l'engagement du président
de la République Monsieur Hollande
qui était quand même le démontage d'une
filière archi profitable
exportatrice qui investissait et donc
pour nous et mon équipe c'était un
énorme problème
notre analyse était que l'engagement du
président de la République ne pourrait
jamais tenu parce qu'il menait à
l'impasse je vous dis franchement
il était impossible de réduire à 50% en
13 ans sans fermer de réacteurs par an
et pour une raison simple comme c'était
de l'électricité pilotable il faudrait
réouvrir les centrales à charbon et au
gaz qu'on me demandait de fermer avec la
ministre de l'écologie d'ailleurs
j'allais sur les sites dire aux
travailleurs quand même je suis allé
croix dans le dans le Nord dans une
c'était pas très content quand même
qu'on leur annonce c'était la fin du
charbon
de l'histoire donc on nous demandait de
faire une centrale charmant mais on
savait que si on fermait des réacteurs
nucléaires il se passerait exactement ce
qui s'est passé en Allemagne c'est
qu'ils ont réouvert ils ont fermé 11
centrales nucléaires Madame Merkel les
en ont ouvert 10 centrales à charbon et
au gaz en même temps c'est exactement ce
qui risquait de se passer et tout le
monde en avait conscience la Belgique
est exactement en train de faire la même
chose
et en même temps il n'y avait pas de
capacité de remplacement par les
énergies renouvelables en si peu de
temps je rappelle qu'un réacteur fermé
nous en avions fait l'analyse c'est 800
éoliennes à installer par acteur donc
qui vous permet où est-ce qu'on va les
mettre et ça coûte 4 milliards donc on
détruit des capacités de production
profitables amorties qui peuvent encore
durer un certain temps et plusieurs
décennies et il fallait remplacer par
des nouvelles capacités donc tout ça
n'avait aucun sens c'était une impasse à
la fois technique économique financière
et industrielle
je vous fais passer une note des trois
services la direction du Trésor de
l'Agence des participations de l'État et
la Direction Générale des Entreprises
s'appelait La dg6 à l'époque du 3 juin
2014 qui explique l'impasse c'est une
note destinée au ministre donc là dedans
il se définance l'économie je l'étais il
industrie tous ceux qui étaient à Bercy
donc cette note elle est vous verrez
qu'elle est tout à fait claire sur la
nature de l'impasse et évidemment pour
nous on allait fermer des usines
des centrales nucléaires archi
profitables amorti certifié par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire envoyer
les employés au chômage donc c'était de
la destruction de valeur pure par bêtise
politique
fait inédit dans l'histoire des
commissions d'enquête sous la 5ème
république l'Assemblée nationale entend
deux anciens présidents de la République
Nicolas Sarkozy et François Hollande
auditionnait le même jour les deux
anciens chefs d'État exposent leur
vision de la politique énergétique de la
France en défendant le bilan de leur
quinquennat l'audition de Nicolas
Sarkozy est celle de François Hollande
ont parfois pris des allures de duel à
distance plus de 10 ans après
l'affrontement des deux hommes au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle en
d'abord je veux dire que le nucléaire
est un sujet de président de la
République
pourquoi
parce que c'est un sujet d'indépendance
majeur
et parce que les décisions en matière de
nucléaire sont des décisions non pas des
cadres
ça décade au pluriel
le mandat de 5 ans même mandat de 7 ans
ne suffit pas je l'ai vu mais mettre les
éoliennes au large de
Pays de la Loire les éoliennes
c'est moi qui les ai décidé mais elles
ont été inaugurées non pas par mon
successeur
mais par Monsieur Macron donc c'est vous
dire le continuum
cantonucléaire il a fait l'objet d'un
consensus politique
j'ai été ministre de Monsieur Mitterrand
pendant la cohabitation
c'est pas lui qui m'a nommé mais je l'ai
eu comme président il n'a jamais mis en
cause le nucléaire
donc le nucléaire c'est la première idée
c'est un sujet de président de la
République ça veut pas dire que le
président est un ingénieur ça veut pas
dire que je suis capable de vous
expliquer le processus mais c'est un
sujet qui remonte sur le bureau du
président de la République ce n'est pas
j'ai il souffre j'ai été ministre
ministre d'État mais ce n'est pas un
ministre seul fut-il le ministre de
l'Industrie
qui peut décider vous voyez bien que le
s'engage trop de monde et trop l'avenir
toute ma vie
toute ma vie politique j'ai pensé que la
filière nucléaire était une chance pour
la France
je n'ai jamais changé d'avis sur ce
sujet c'est le droit d'autre d'avoir un
autre avis
et j'ai d'ailleurs été très souvent
accusé de faire partie comme dit tant du
lobby nucléaire tu ne plaisanterie le
seul lobby qui existe c'est le lobby
anti nucléaire
le levier anti-nucléaire est beaucoup
plus puissant que le bisucléaire puisque
le lobby anti-nucléaire bénéficier
pendant des années la bienveillance
médiatique
pourquoi je suis pour le nucléaire j'ai
pas changé c'est pas très original ce
que je vais dire à ce point là
mais parfois il y a des idées vraies
qui doivent être martelés
rappeler et c'est pas parce qu'elles
sont pas originales qu'elles ne sont pas
exactes on entend tellement de bêtises
j'ai toujours été pour le nucléaire pour
une raison première simple c'est que
nous n'avons pas d'énergie fossile
et c'est pas parce que c'est connu que
ça doit pas être rappelé tout part de là
si nous avions des énergies fossiles
naturellement la discussion serait tout
autre
la deuxième chose
pour remplir nos objectifs
environnementaux
nous avons besoin d'une clé
les plus préoccupés
par le réchauffement climatique devait
être les premiers défenseurs du
nucléaire la vérité elle est là
plus
vous payez du réchauffement climatique
plus vous êtes préoccupé des hommes des
questions environnementales plus vous
devez être pour le nucléaire c'est un
vrai semblable qu'il en soit le
contraire comme si on devait opposer
énergies renouvelable énergie nucléaire
ça n'a aucun sens
les partisans de l'énergie de nucléaire
sont tous pour les énergies
renouvelables les partisans de l'énergie
renouvelables beaucoup sont contre
l'énergie nucléaire il doit être pour
je vous dis une chose
nous ne pourrons pas remplir nos
objectifs
environnementaux vous voyez ce que je
veux dire sur les objectifs
environnementaux des missions si nous
n'avons pas l'énergie nucléaire
troisième argument pour lequel je suis
pour le nucléaire il est moins mis en
avant mais il est absolument capital
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
la filière nucléaire
accumulé pendant 70 ans un potentiel
extraordinaire de compétences
technologiques
qui ne sert pas que pour les nucléaires
c'est une filière qui tire derrière elle
au fond toute l'industrie
et le moindre signal de remise en
question d'une claire
remet en question une filière de
formation monsieur le Président il faut
des années pour que les meilleures
étudiants nos meilleures ingénieurs
soient formés si vous envoyez un signal
négatif sur l'industrie nucléaire vous
cassez
la formation durablement
c'est un peu comme l'affaire vous savez
des quotas pour les médecins
un gouvernement prend une décision de
mettre des quotas sur la formation de
médecins sur le moment la décision est
totalement inodore 10 ans après vous
rendez compte qu'il manque des médecins
parce qu'il faut 10 ans profondément
et donc nous avions nous avons là une
filière fantastique
scientifique de haut niveau
technologique qui traînent tout le monde
vers le haut
je suis pour nucléaire parce que de
toutes les énergies
c'est celle qui produit le moins
nuisances visuel comme sonore parce que
faut qu'on prenne une chose il y a pas
une énergie qui soit totalement neutre
forme d'énergie et justement parce que
c'est de l'énergie produit des effets
négatifs plus ou moins grands mais il
n'y a pas une énergie
disponible qui n'est pas d'effet négatif
ou indésirables et enfin je suis pour le
nucléaire parce que
c'est grâce à ça que nous avions eu
l'électricité la moins chère
voire appeler ça
on se dit mais c'est tellement évident
comme moi peut-il exister des gens quand
le nucléaire parce que je viens de dire
encore une fois n'a rien d'original non
c'est incontestable c'est absolument
incontestable bon il y a pas besoin
d'être polytechnicien pour comprendre ça
alors
non seulement tu as gravé mon cas
je suis pour le nucléaire je l'ai
toujours été
mais j'ai voulu faire un petit travail
rapide je vous rassure
pour récapituler tous les aiguillages
enfin pardon tous les moments
d'aiguillages aiguillages vous comprenez
ou sur votre bureau arrive une décision
vous la prenez vous la prenez pas on
peut pas faire ça ça m'intéresse pas
l'énergie nucléaire de nucléaire c'est
pas pour moi je suis un juriste donc je
comprends pas j'y touche pas
donc toute ma vie politique j'ai pris
des décisions en faveur de la filière
nucléaire toute ma vie politique
quelques furent mes fonctions
mais pire
je les ai toujours assumées publiquement
quel que soit le prix politique à payer
parce que maintenant c'est facile d'être
pour nucléaire j'en vois qui
j'en vois qui font des doubles salto des
triples salto arrière nous y reviendrons
parce que là maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus facile
mais je vais dire une première chose là
le nucléaire a fait l'objet d'une
campagne de dénigrement digne des
chasses aux sorcières du Moyen-Âge
irrationnel
mensongère
et on peut dire que les premières fake
news
c'est là
c'était une hystérie médiatique et
collective
qu'il reposait et je le démontrerai sur
rien
donc c'est pas tout de prendre des
décisions pour le nucléaire
il fallait les assumer parce que quand
vous étiez pro nucléaire ouh là là alors
là vous étiez pas moderne vous verrez la
succession de période d'investissement
massif et de période d'arrêt
peut-être destructeur pour une filière
d'une telle intensité technologique je
vous dis une chose
les signaux désastreux politique
idéologique qui ont été envoyés
ont découragé les meilleurs de nos
étudiants d'aller dans la filière
nucléaire
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
la Parole du politique ça compte
et contrairement à ce qu'on dit l'action
commence par les mots les manques un
sens
surtout en France
on a l'amour des mots
et quand vous les politiques vous avez
peur du nucléaire vous envoyez un signal
que vous allez détruire cette filière
parce que attention
l'arrêter c'est le détruire
c'est comme si vous m'expliquez
que l'Atlantique l'océan Indien et le
Pacifique il y a pas de marée
avec le nucléaire vous avancez vous
reculez vous vivez vous mourrez c'est ça
la filière technique d'autres intensité
vient alors le débat d'entre-deux tours
avec Nicolas Sarkozy j'ai cru comprendre
que vous aviez reçu mon prédécesseur et
qu'il a toujours cette façon qui le rend
particulièrement attractif au moins
auprès de ces amis et j'en suis heureux
pour lui et donc je me suis replongé
dans le débat qui nous avait animé l'un
des l'autre dans ce débat donc d'avril
2012 sujet du nucléaire vient
nécessairement compte tenu de
l'importance et du caractère régalien de
choix que le Président de la République
doit faire généralement au début de son
mandat et donc Nicolas Sarkozy mais je
peux comprendre cette attitude dans un
débat utilise l'accord qui vient d'être
passé entre les vers et le Parti
socialiste sauf que je lui dis que je ne
suis pas engagé par cet accord
et que j'ai donc cette déclaration que
je refais devant lui hélas sans sa
présence mais
je pense que je peux m'adresser encore à
lui je veux garder le nucléaire comme
source principale de production
d'électricité mais réduire sa part à
mesure que les énergies renouvelables
vont monter en production et comme le
débat se prolon je dis bon écoutez
vous voulez garder toutes les centrales
moi je
veux faire une centrale et j'en ouvrirai
une autre Flamanville ce sera la seule
position que je prendrai sur les
centrales durant mon mandat
je veux pas anticiper sur la suite je
n'ai même pas fermé fait cela dure au
moment mais je revendique cette décision
devait fermer dès lors que Flamanville
devait ouvrir c'est sur cette position
là très claire
50%, une Centrale qui devait fermer
Flamanville qui devait se poursuivre et
le maintien de ce qui faisait la force
de notre industrie nucléaire que je me
suis présenté devant les Français et
qu'ils m'ont accordé leur confiance
alors même que la position majoritaire
de nos concitoyens à cette époque
étaient sans doute très défavorable au
nucléaire et que je considérais que ma
responsabilité
pas simplement de candidats de futurs
président de la République si les
Français m'accordaient leur confiance
c'était de maintenir la filière
nucléaire et de la matière à haut niveau
deuxième
interrogation que je veux poser pour
revenir sur cette année 2012 quel était
l'état de la filière nucléaire lorsque
j'arrive aux responsabilités en 2012
la dernière décision de construction
d'une centrale nucléaire en France
daté de 2005 c'était Jacques Chirac
président de la République pas son
ministre d'État non c'était Jacques
Chirac président de la République qui a
décidé de lancer une nouvelle France
centrale flammeville nous sommes en 2005
il prend une décision importante mais il
fait le choix d'un exemplaire unique
sans effet de ces risques et la grande
différence par rapport aux grands
programmes qui avaient été lancé
précédemment
le Pr donc devait être livré en 2012
et je rappelle qu'il ne l'est toujours
pas 11 ans après donc il y a
aucune décision qui a été prise durant
le mandat de Nicolas Sarkozy de lancer
des centrales
il y a que celle de Jacques Chirac qui
doit trouver son aboutissement
durant la période où moi-même j'accède à
la présidente de la République
sur Pandi puisque il y avait un projet
de lancer un deuxième réacteur à Polly
cette décision en 2011 avait été reporté
dans quête publique avait été plusieurs
fois
repoussé et
en octobre
2011 EDF et le gouvernement décide de
renvoyer à après 2012 l'enquête de bonly
je vais ajouter un dernier élément c'est
que durant le mandat de mon prédécesseur
fais cela m'avait déjà été évoqué comme
pouvant éventuellement fermer vous avez
reçu
madame constucio-morizet
qui a donné un argument supplémentaire
en parlant du radier c'est-à-dire le
plancher en béton de la centrale qui
était plus fin que celui de toutes les
autres centrales et elle a héritérée
devant vous en déclarant que l'épaisseur
n'atteignait pas le niveau de sûreté de
troisième génération
mais moi ce qui me paraissait le plus
essentiel c'était que nous pouvions
faire de Fessenheim alors que nous
savions que dans 10 ans dans 15 ans nous
aurions a fermé des centrales parce
qu'elles arrivaient au terme de leur vie
ils soient possibles sur le site de
Fessenheim d'enfer un centre de
recherche pour précisément la
prolongation des centrales et l'hôtel
est le démantèlement
cette décision est le message de
modernisation peut-être
ainsi énoncer la plus vieille de l'eau
centrale était remplacée par la plus
moderne en l'occurrence le père de
flamonville et c'est le lien qui a été
établi notamment dans la loi de
transition énergétique dont vous avez
parlé la loi de 2015 j'en dis donc
quelques mots la loi de 2015 d'abord a
été précédée par un grand débat
énergétique avec toutes les parties
prenantes patronales syndicat et du
locaux et bien sûr ONG
c'est Madame bateau qui avait été chargé
de ce débat et je pense qu'elle l'a
parfaitement menée après faire d'autres
choix mais lorsque Madame Ségolène
ministre de l'écologie présente la loi
de 2015 c'est inspiré par ce que ce
débat a pu fournir la loi de 2015 c'est
la première fois que un texte du
Parlement vient fixer les objectifs
d'une politique de transition
énergétique et
crée deux instruments pour que cette
politique puisse être traduite les PPE
et la stratégie backgargo bas carbone
deuxièmement
si le l'objectif de 50% à l'horizon 2025
et rappeler il n'a pas de force
obligatoire
puisque c'est un horizon qui est défini
il n'a pas de caractère normatif et
d'ailleurs il ne fait l'objet d'aucune
trajectoire
la seule disposition qui est entrée en
vigueur et qui peut avoir un caractère
contraignant nous y reviendrons c'est le
plafonnement de
63,2 gigawatts de puissance installé en
capacité de production nucléaire
le 6 avril 2023 après près de six mois
de travaux Raphaël berger et Antoine
Armand présente leur rapport à la presse
un rapport sans concession qui invite
avec 30 propositions à ne pas reproduire
les erreurs du passé
disons les choses clairement ces
auditions ont suscité chez moi chez les
membres de la commission de l'étonnement
et parfois de la consternation parce que
le récit qui s'est reconstitué devant
nous c'est bien le récit d'une lente
dérive d'une forme de divagation
politique une divagation qui nous a
éloigné et de la transition écologique
et de notre souveraineté énergétique
c'est l'histoire du lien souvent
défaillant parfois même inexistant à
vrai dire entre l'expertise scientifique
et technique d'une part l'instruction
des dossiers et la décision politique
c'est l'histoire de rapport qui l'aurait
peut-être fallu lire relire ou parfois
simplement penser à commander
c'est donc aussi l'histoire de décision
souvent partielle différée c'est enfin
malheureusement l'histoire de décision
prise à l'envers sans méthode sans
prospective aux conséquences lourdes et
qui ne semblaient trouver leurs sources
disons le simplement que dans
l'inconscience ou dans l'électoralisme
nous sommes que des responsables
politiques
la solution technologique en matière de
d'innovation de rupture de gamechanger
comme on dit dans le milieu des start-up
c'est pas à nous de la trouver notre
responsabilité c'est de la permettre
et pour la permettre notre boulot c'est
le rapport de la société à ces questions
énergétiques et la place du débat
énergétique et la façon dont il est
animé dans le débat public c'est pas
nous qui allons construire des centrales
nucléaires c'est pas nous qu'elle en
construire des pas nous qu'allons
imaginer
je sais pas moi
le réacteur assez le fondu qui qui sera
la rupture technologique de demain ou la
captation du carbone dans l'air que on
pourra mettre en énergie liquide dans
les moteurs thermiques d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas nous qu'avons le faire
ce que fait notre rapport ce que change
notre commission d'enquête
c'est la perception de la du caractère
essentiel de ce sujet dans le débat
public
je pense que ce qu'on a réussi c'est
d'en faire un vrai sujet c'est ces six
derniers mois quand on voit comment nos
travaux étaient suivis
sur les réseaux sociaux
sur la plateforme de l'Assemblée sur les
plateformes de vidéos
certaines auditions dépassent les deux
millions de vues
pour des travaux parlementaires c'est
quand même un truc qui est assez
atypique
maintenant le vrai défi pour nous
c'est comment on fait en sorte que cette
pression que met la représentation
populaire qui siège à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ces questions énergétiques
ne cessent pas avec la fin de la
commission d'enquête le vrai défi pour
nous c'est celui-là c'est pas de trouver
la solution miracle parce que nous ne
sommes que des politiques
mais c'est de continuer à animer cette
intérêt et cette pression populaire sur
la question énergétique
les travaux des députés ont reçu un
accueil large au sein du grand public
chose plutôt rare pour une commission
d'enquête parlementaire
un système numéro des grands débats on
se retrouve très vite sur LCP pour un
autre moment parlementaire
[Musique]